qu'ils viennent ces clubs de maths ou
sur le corps ou les renois et les robots
ont
leur [ __ ] leur mère à ses fils du
[Musique]
dans mes filles agents médias jetons
mais c'est pourquoi il est temps de
ramener les renoir avec ta tête chameau
pas d'où tu viens taper de la loupe
jamais ça jamais dire jamais pourquoi
tout est tombé groupe e et l'hérault
n'en oublie pas
pourquoi qui fait le mytho ton prénom
c'est au sol ta bouche dans le caca qui
parlent sont d'une tarte
en tout sur le cac
tu parles c'est une tare talent
[Musique]
m
toujours
[Musique]
là qu'ils viennent ces clubs doivent
tous sur le camp des troubles en place
sur les plages au j'aimerais bien toi
dans le ghetto la conter des histoires
de femmes de ta tête tu jamais jean
médecines douces et la vraie vie les
médias ont décidé d'éliminer racj a
déclaré
jean mais pourquoi tu es tombé à côté
non
tout est pas d'où tu viens ta mère et la
loupe jamais jamais dire jamais pourquoi
tu et en egypte et les monoplaces et
break la tête charmontois amputer un
obstacle
ou plus proche où tu viens
coupure le rap était est un champ de
haine alors voilà donc ça sort ce soir à
minuit
champion score non mais non ma leçon
j'aime bien le son après il ya
deux-trois pas la parole qui me dérange
s'appelle en fait c'est ce que c'est une
illustration de ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est à dire qu'une partie du
rap c'est un fait call home haineux dont
les saint georges vers les étoiles et
dont les cibles de ce nouveau chanter
ton prénom je peux je peux venir qu'ils
fassent la vérité tu atteins ou pas le
fond j'ai kiffé sommé par son verdict
voilà mais tous les jeunes je sais que
pouvoir laisser loin de venir parce que
sinon c'est rudi allons messieurs je dis
juste que le rap et se fait qu'à lomé ne
vous allez vous que vous venez de voir
dont les six balles noires heureuse en
boucane l'environnement à tous les jeux
voilà alors je te laisse chercher on dit
que c'est d'eux dont on était tous
jeunes ou chanté oh mais j'ai eu droit
quand j'étais jeune j'ai eu droit à tous
les jeux de mots que tu manges je te
passe sous l'eau honnêtement la ctd que
suce mon book que suspens baudelaire
quoi c'est vraiment c'est niveau zéro de
l'écriture au dessus c'est beau ça
surprend agents nécessaires pour essayer
d'être un peu à la hauteur leur n
importe quoi ces messieurs c'est
agressif on a pris un peu de talent la
c-zéro quoi parce que t'as pas sa
culture dans mes paupières fermées
chiant en total désaccord avec jean
messi a très souvent et tout le temps
d'ailleurs parce que j'exècre la
politique qui le défend très clairement
mais là vous lui mettez une cible dans
le dos c'est juste dégueulasse avec
l'abitre éclaté c'est quoi c'est pas une
balle qu'on tire dans une vitre ça non
la différence entre l'expression avons
facilement tomber
faire la différence entre ceux en
exprime par une poésie par hacavie la
zone autrement de violence une
agressivité et le passage à l'acte c'est
précisément l'art qui permet de
médiatiser immédiat c'est dommage je
suis juste un jeu devient un art et je
suis un artiste et shore une chanson
comme ça en chantant et en mettant
monsieur jean mêlée c'est pas nous qui
ont cours à madras ya un truc qui
m'énerve c'est que tu vas je suspends ce
boom bon aux hommes
pourquoi tu critiques
[Musique]
si tu es arabe n'a pas douté quand il a
parlé d bah oui c'est cela il faut des
idées c'est une radio c'est immédiat
sous le tir sur les idées toutes les
gendarmes le jour c'est quoi ces sources
boum quand vous dites je bang bang c'est
sur les itanium et c'est en fait la
france et je préside et une razzia bang
bang bang c'est que les idées de bons
tirs sur cd que c'est prendre les choses
dans leur contexte et pas trop de ça
c'est nous qu'on est encore en vie quand
on parle pas laxistes j'entends qu'à
voir mais c'est beau c'est subversif
c'est la mission d'un artiste de
déranger et tout ça on est on est
d'accord avec cette affirmation sauf
quand on parle du rap et du hip hop h et
un aplomb généralement généralement va
les unir allemand on ne parle de ça les
gens qui disent assez des gens qui
n'écoutent pas le rap tout à leurs
raquettes à neige c'est un homme talât
parole de renault on peut rappeler je
suis pour de sardou est aujourd'hui
sardou est ce qu'il est blacklisté non
on vient de le remettre une décoration
voilà on n'est pas la même époque juste
moins faible il est pour lâcher ses
grands dieux avec jura rouge j'ai grandi
avec du rap j'écoutais la mafia k 1 fry
j'écoutais kelly james mois kery james a
été de la poésie un espoir et c'est ici
que j'ai pu se lever le matin je me suis
levé le maintenant je me suis levé le
matin en écoutant banlieusards et fier
de l'être on n'est pas condamné à
l'échec je me suis levé avec ça tous les
matins scénaristique puisque je suis
devenu aujourd'hui yanam et plein de
gens qui écoutent europe la grande
majorité aucun n'est donc six français
aucun les délinquants donc ça c'est de
l'humour juste pour finir la science et
de l'art fait de leur leur a fait défaut
aujourd'hui génial de tout et puis les
rémois justement jean messias eric
chelle demont comme sur un autre débat
qu'on a eue sur l'immigration en fait il
n'explique la délinquance par
l'immigration ou par le rap au lieu de
se concentrer sur les vrais gaullistes
earth et les vraies causes de la
délinquance à lire et à la madeleine
mais c'est l'étiage m'explique est ce
que vous pensez vraiment pu sont
ridicules de gens mais ça jusqu'au bout
imaginez un un délinquant face à un
magistrat qui me dit bon j'avoue j'ai
écouté le dernier album de booba c'est
pour ça que je rentrais dans le grand
banditisme
non mais vous avez craqué faut boire de
l'eau verte nationale est en aucun cas
un appel au meurtre peut être considéré
comme de l'arbre c'est la lazio
fini le nom de messier argent car ce
cache mal les opinions fait associé tirs
de balles suivre l'impact des balles et
bien amusé